alles kommt ist der neue film von mia
hansen darf mit isabelle huppert in der
hauptrolle
sie spielt eine philosophieprofessorin
kann man nicht simone partie durch
gelogen den kenn ich
ein schrecklicher stalinist ist eure
mutter hat kommunistische flugblätter
verteilt hatte ich sie kennengelernt
sie war für terrorakt ich war kommunist
drei jahre lang habe ich mich nicht
daher reitet ebenfalls mit einem
philosophie-professor seinerseits der
hauptsächlich schopenhauer liest was uns
vielleicht auf die richtige spur bringt
es geht darum um die frage was passiert
wenn ein lebendes eigentlichen
geordneten bürgerlichen wann läuft jetzt
ohne große höhepunkte aber auch ohne not
und ohne streit ohne große unglücksfälle
sondern einfach nur ein leben das sich
eingerichtet hat mit dem kümmern am eine
hysterisch depressive mutter mit den im
leben der studenten mit und schülern mit
dem familienleben zwei erwachsenen
kindern was passiert wenn all das
plötzlich auseinander fällt ist das die
große tragödie
oder ist das unter umständen auch eine
ganz große chance für diese frau die
eben vor allen dingen nachdenkt und auch
diese situation des zerfalls ihres
lebens eigentlich mit denken begegnet
ich habe eine andere frau kennt was soll
denn das
warum erzählst du mir das hättest du das
nicht für dich behalten können ich will
mit dir zusammen leben das tolle an
diesem film ist es dieser welt ob er in
der hauptrolle sie heißt nennt amy ist
die ununterbrochen in bewegung ist und
zwar schnell
sie denkt schnell sie geht schnell sie
rast von hier nach da sie packt ihre
bücher ein
sie kocht sogar schnell in diesen polare
kocht geht das alles in einem affenzahn
eine ungeheure dynamik in diesem film
ich glaube es ist ein film für alle
leute die ebenfalls gerne nachdenken und
zwar gar nicht jetzt unbedingt über
philosophische fragen im sinne einer
meiner gesamtheit sondern die einfach
ihr leben zu begreifen versuchen und zu
begreifen versuchen was zählt und zu
begreifen versuchen wie sie dahin kommen
und wie sie es mich fallen lassen
manchmal habe ich das gefühl uns frauen
ab 40 kann man einfach auf den müll
werfen
wie kannst du so was sagen vor allem du
das ist die wahrheit glaub mir
kennst du frauen in meinem alter die
ihre männer verlassen ich bin sicher da
gibt es viele den film vielleicht du
wirst bestimmt ganz schnell wieder
jemanden finden das tolle ist dass man
bei der natalie dass man denkt ja sie
fragt die richtigen dinge sieht die
dinge offen deswegen ist der deutsche
titel alles bald kommt obwohl herr
wirklich sehr und elegant das ist
eigentlich traurig sie sagt einer
sie ist zum ersten mal frei in ihrem
leben in dem moment wo der mann sie
verlassen hat die mutter ist tot und
einen buchvertrag hat sie auch nicht
mehr so kann man die sache natürlich
auch sehen insofern ist es auch bei
aller männer kuli natürlich auch ein
lustiger film
es gibt sogar leute überhaupt nur seine
tragikomödie
ich finde es wie ein tragödie noch eine
komödie noch eine tragikomödie sondern
einfach ein ganz wunderschöner leicht
melancholischer geborene haben eine
besonderheit vielleicht auch insofern
als sie eben so ein bisschen alte schule
noch sind das interessante ist aber dass
das und das war von anfang an dass auch
eine große rolle gespielt
zusammen gedacht wird mit den zarten
technologien mit einer mehr seite zu tun
hat und es ist natürlich unter diesen
umständen sehr viel schwieriger als ich
davon zu machen